bonjour à tous
je suis hyper hyper content d'être là
tmx pour moi ça a été une énorme source
d'inspiration depuis je pense ces dix
dernières années donc si aujourd'hui
vous me voyez un peu plus hésitant que
d'habitude c'est que franchement j'ai
les miquettes parce que dans un coin de
ma tête je me dis que peut-être dans dix
ans il y aura un autre mec sur cette
scène qui sera inspiré par cette
conférence comme j'ai pu l'être moi ya
dix ans
donc je m'appelle boire peut-être
certains d'entre vous en effet comme on
a pu l'entendre dans la présentation
connaît sous le nom de major mouvement
et j'ai deux passions dans la vie
la première c'est le corps humain et
j'en ai fait mon métier je suis kiné et
la deuxième c'est comprendre l'humain et
j'ai réussi à en faire aussi mon métier
en créant du contenu sur les réseaux
sociaux
alors pratiquement quand je dis aux gens
que je suis kiné à ses vitrines samassa
combien j'ai mal à l'épaule ça te dirait
de regarder surtout en soirée vers de 3
heures du matin en plus en ce moment les
gens me reconnaissent de plus en plus du
coup quand je vais dans un bar c'est
soir des lieux de consultation assez
insolite et la deuxième chose c'est que
par contre quand je dis que je suis
créateur de contenu les gens dit ah bon
ok cool et c'est quoi ton pseudo déjà
mais on voir sur instagram et ils font
ça à chaque fois
puis thomas jean mathia vachement gens
qui te suivent tu dois dire des trucs
intéressants
je me suis quand même cogné quatre à
cinq années d'études pour devenir kiné
et juste les réseaux sociaux ont permis
de faire entendre son message un peu
plus fort et c'est ça que j'ai envie de
transmettre aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler un peu du mal de dos c'est quand
même c'est cool moi ça me passionne
mais surtout je vais vous parler de
communication
et je vais vous expliquer comment on
fait en tout le temps un peu mon message
j'ai pu apprendre plein de choses il ya
un truc que j'ai appris et ça j'ai
appris pendant mes 8 ans de carrière de
kiné où je me suis assez souvent cassé
les dents quand même faut le dire c'est
que ça ne sert à rien
oublier deux fois ça sert à rien
d'essayer de convaincre les autres de
prendre soin d'eux
y compris si c'est pour leur bien
alors en tant que kiné mon job
principalement c'est de donner des
conseils aux gens ça demande des
connaissances anatomiques mécanique
médical et je pensais au début de ma
carrière que ça suffisait en fait que
juste de savoir
permettait de convaincre les gens
que si jamais tu veux aider les gens
autour de toi il suffit juste de leur
donner une bonne information et puis
après ils vont le faire et puis ça va
bien se passer
mais en fait ce n'est pas suffisant pour
pouvoir transmettre son savoir bien au
delà de la kiné si tu veux aider les
gens autour de toi il faut d'autres
compétences
la transmission du savoir ça n'est pas
le savoir
il faut des compétences en communication
il faut de l'empathie faut de la
patience et on va le voir il faut un
outil qui absolument indispensable mais
je vous le dirai juste après vous allez
voir la 7e raison va vous étonner
alors juste rapidement
pour garder un peu de suspense
je vous parlais d'un truc je vais vous
expliquer juste en 30 secondes le mal de
dos pourquoi moi sam anime tous les
jours
huit personnes sur dix ils seront
confrontés au cours de leur vie
c'est la deuxième cause de consultation
chez le médecin généraliste et chaque
année ça coûte un milliard d'euros à la
sécurité sociale c'est un vrai sujet le
mal de dos et les solutions nous
professionnels de santé on les a
voilà comment j'ai bossé pendant huit
ans et globalement mes patients c'est
une image d'un psy mais ça marche aussi
parce que souvent nos patients nous
racontent beaucoup de trucs mais nous
racontent souvent les mêmes idées reçues
par rapport à leur mal de dos c'est ma
mauvaise posture
c'est faux aucun lien entre la mauvaise
posture et mal de dos c'est mon bassin
décalé qui s'est encore décalé c'est
faux les seuls the skies se déplacer au
cours d'une grosse fracture et ça ça n'a
rien à voir chez un kiné vous allez
passer une radio et c'est chez le
médecin c'est ma colonne qui n'est pas
droite heureusement la colonne
vertébrale n'est pas droite elles
s'enchaînent pour qu'on puisse bouger sa
mère ni fiscal alors autant une hernie
fiscal ça peut faire
vraiment mal aux fesses mais ça
s'appelle une hernie discale
et globalement on va tous en avoir une
c'est l'évolution naturelle du dos et
c'est pas forcément problématique ou
c'est parce que j'ai pris trois kilos
alors les études sont assez formel
contrairement aux idées reçues la prise
de poids n'a pas de lien avec le mal de
dos ça n'a rien à voir
donc à chaque fois en fait les gens me
donnait des désirs des reçus et puis moi
pendant huit ans j'ai uniquement
confronté ce que je considère être leur
croyance à mes connaissances
c'était souvent conflictuelles dire que
moi je savais j'étais dans mon bon droit
j'avais étudié pour et leur disais non
vous avez tort c'est moi qui résout
j'essayais de les convaincre
alors ça marchait j'ai sauté la slide
bon c'était juste un mec dans son lit
sachant que l'on soumet
en soi d'être en conflit perpétuel c'est
quand même pas très confortable ni pour
eux ni pour moi j'avais des résultats
plutôt bons mais sur le court terme
j'arrivais pas à modifier leur manière
de vivre sur le long terme
en fait assez simplement pour le mal de
dos les solutions à court terme vous
apporteront des résultats l'ont à court
terme mais si vous voulez des résultats
sur le long terme il faut plutôt voir la
chose de manière un peu plus globale le
mal de dos c'est plutôt la surface de
l'iceberg
parce que le vrai iceberg c'est la
sédentarité
et la sédentarité c'est un peu plus
complexe parce que là on va avoir des
vrais trucs que juste quelqu'un qui a
mal au dos on va avoir des risques
cardiovasculaires des dégénérescence
mentale des douleurs articulaires des
troubles du sommeil est globalement un
peu beaucoup de pathologies qui vont
être augmentées par la sédentarité
et nous professionnels de santé on a une
solution qui est très simple il marche
très bien pour ça qui a fait ses preuves
on a beaucoup de preuves de la
littérature scientifique sur un
médicament qui est très simple qui est
gratos qui et c'est ce qui est assez
stylé
quelle activité physique
est là globalement je vous assure ça
fait 10 ans que lui dans le métier mon
métier tient juste dance à faire en
sorte que des gens qui bougent pas on
arrive à les faire bouger
et pour ça il suffit pas juste
de dire que ça diminue toutes les
complications de la sédentarité ça
marche pas c'est pas suffisant
et cette question là comment est ce que
je peux modifier le mode vus de mes
passions elle m'a hanté pendant huit ans
je donne un petit exemple qui n'a rien à
voir avec mon métier mais juste pour
vous montrer
pourquoi est ce que nos messages en
temps professionnels de santé ont du mal
à passer rappelez vous il ya deux ans la
première fois on a parlé de dispensation
social on se foutait de ma gueule quoi
t'es sûr que le virus il peut faire un
mètre cinquante et pas de m on va pas se
laver les mains 35 fois par jour les
masses ça sert à rien
c'est difficile de faire passer un
message y compris pour le bien des gens
alors pourquoi nous qui sache où on a
autant de mal à faire passer nos
connaissances
alors j'ai réfléchi ça c'est moi quand
je réfléchis et comme là je réfléchis
beaucoup vraiment
et au départ je bloquais sur un truc
j'étais convaincu que si notre message
ne passait pas c'est qu'il y avait
d'autres informations qui passait à la
place
et ses informations principalement c'est
celle qui sont en permanence sur vos
smartphones sur vos navigateurs internet
sur l'eau n'importe quelle connexion
c'est de la désinformation défèque med
et du marketing
et ces produits là vous les voyez passer
en permanence
et dans un coin de votre tête vous savez
que c'est pas vrai c'est pas possible
que ça marche
mais quand même 28 balle sais pas si
cher
peut-être que dans le doute si on
l'achète on aura peut-être moins mal au
dos puis c'est plus facile de croire un
mensonge que d'envisager un changement
profond
donc en fait la désinformation médical
pour moi c'était mon ennemi numéro un
parce que c'était plus facile de trouver
un ennemi que de me remettre en question
donc pendant des années
j'ai eu beaucoup de colère
j'ai eu beaucoup de colère contre sa
présence est pas normal de vivre dans un
système qui tolère que du marketing
fallacieux s'exprime à la place des
professionnels de santé
et quand retenue quand on se retrouvait
un comme ça on entend continuer parce
que je suis prof aussi on était tous là
à ce fichier s'exprime à notre place il
raconte des conneries et nous on peut
rien faire
j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de colère en
moi
et un jour j'ai eu un déclic
et c'est avec un patient
c'était il ya quatre ans
j'avais monté mon cabinet de kiné je
travaillais beaucoup pour lancer mon
activité je mousse je bossais quasiment
10 à 12 heures par jour six jours sur
sept
c'était ici pour information je le dis
pas sur les réseaux sociaux mais où donc
est menée là
et mon cabinet il est juste à côté d'une
petite pme qui fabrique des avions donc
principalement
les gens qui viennent me voir ils ont à
peu près mon âge entre 30 et 50 piges
et ça se passe bien avec ce patient il
est cool on discute bien et je les
écoute
il est un peu branché rugby moi aussi et
du goût entre rugbyman souvent brise la
glace assez rapidement il me dit us à
greg je n'ai jamais dit à personne mais
ça fait deux ans que j'ai du mal quand
je fais l'amour à ma femme
et je me demande pourquoi on dit parce
que j'arrive plus à bouger le dos
alors je fais mon bilan classique 1 il
ya aucun signe anatomique problématique
du coup je lui demande de bouger un peu
c'est comme ça
je vous laisse imaginer la scène parce
que je me la suis imaginé aussi c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué ça enlève un
beau panel de liberté sexuelle
le dit ok bagot gelé mis devant le
miroir jouer et demi je lui ai mis les
deux mains sur le bassin niveau de ces
crête iliaque lui ai fait des mouvements
super simple rétroversion en des
versions de bassins et je lui ai appris
à faire ça devant le miroir
ça donne quoi ça donne l'air coin je
vous invite à le faire vous pouvez le
faire en toute discrétion devant le
miroir des petites âmes c'est pas si mal
en fait puis sexuellement sa moue des
trucs comme ça
et franchement dit [ __ ] mais ça fait
du bien en fait et je lui ai expliqué
ouais on était assis toute la journée
tes fesses ne bouge pas et en bougeant
tu vas juste année du sang années de
l'oxygène dans tes muscles on l'a vu à
l'oxygène c'est important partout en
fait dans nos océans mais aussi dans vos
fesses
et en fait il m'a dit on ne m'a jamais
expliqué ça comme ça
ça a été mon premier déclic je me suis
dit ok greg tu as une capacité à
expliquer les choses
qui fait que ça touche les gens
dans les deux sens du terme et dans
l'autre sens qu'en
aussi je me suis dit ok c'est pas tout
d'avoir de la colère contre ceux qui
s'expriment à ta place
il faut que tu arrives à diffuser ton
message je suis limité par mes patients
un patient par demi-heure ok si je veux
pouvoir m'adresser à plus de personnes
il faut que je change quelque chose il
faut que je bouge
et quelques semaines plus tard j'ai eu
un déclic
et pas de hasard dans la vie c'est un
mec que j'admire beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux qui s'appelle garer hui
il à expliquer la chose suivante
il ya deux façons d'avoir le plus grand
building dans une ville
soit juste eu construit le plus grand
building dans ta ville
soit tu construis ton building et tu
passes ta vie et on énergie à essayer de
détruire celui des autres
et en fait pendant huit ans j'avais
dépensé toute mon énergie juste à
essayer de faire en sorte que les
produits miraculeux arrête de s'exprimer
alors qu'en fait c'était à moi de
m'exprimer
je me suis lancé sur les réseaux sociaux
sur instagram en un mois j'avais dix
mille abonnés
cool
en un an j'en avais cent mille
aujourd'hui ça fait quatre ans que sur
les réseaux sociaux je suis suivi par
plus d'un million de personnes j'ai
vendu un livre qui s'est vendu à 5 50
mille exemplaires
de temps en temps je me farsi quand même
les produits miracles pour le fun
juste pour leur montrer que je suis là
que j'existe mais juste au lieu de
diriger toute mon énergie sur la
négativité sur de la colère le dit ok
quels sont tes capacités à toi pour
transmettre son message
alors
avant de me lancer j'ai pas mal réfléchi
et ça a été mon deuxième troisième
déclic
comment est ce qu'on fait pour se faire
entendre
avant de me lancer sur les réseaux
sociaux en fait j'ai longtemps analysé
le type de communication qu'on avait
nous professionnels de santé de manière
générale
et je me suis dit ce qui pose problème
en fait ce qui fait qu'on ne nous écoute
pas c'est qu'à chaque france met dans la
position du sachant de celui qui sait et
qui va vous expliquer chez certaines
personnes ça ne marche pas
ça ne marche pas d'essayer de convaincre
parce que quand vous essayez de
convaincre vous essayer de vaincre
l'écho c'est comme ça que les gens se
sentent ils sentent qu'on en fait
la première barrière à laquelle vous
allez vous porter quand vous essayez
d'expliquer le cas écrit que sa vie
allait pas terrible tel qu'il a mis qui
feraient mieux de suivre vos conseils
c'est son ego quand vous essayez de
l'avertir lui son ego va faire barrière
et en fait ça va filtrer complètement la
pertinence de votre message
alors comment est ce qu'on fait pour
contourner les goûts des gens
meilleur moyen c'est pas cherché à les
combats c'est pas de chercher à savoir
que vous êtes c'est pas de chercher
pardon alors montrez que vous êtes
supérieur parce que c'est pas le cas
vous avez juste des connaissances que
vous avez envie de partager libre à eux
de les prendre
pour ça d'abord le mieux c'est de les
écouter
quand vous les écoutez vous allez les
valoriser par rapport à leurs
problématiques et on se sentir en
confiance
et du coup vous allez avoir une réponse
individualisée à chaque individu
dans mon cabinet finalement au lieu de
confronter mes connaissances
avec ce que me disaient mes patients je
les écoutais plus quand ils me disaient
c'est ma mauvaise posture c'est pour ça
que j'ai mal au dos je leur demandais
pourquoi est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya
un lien entre la mauvaise posture et la
douleur
quand ils me disent c'est parce que j'ai
pris trois kilos
leur demande juste alors j'ai une bonne
nouvelle je transforme semble positivité
en opportunité la prise de poids n'est
pas en lien avec le mal de dos mais
cependant si jamais c'est chose qui vous
concerne on peut en discuter
on écoute et ensuite on reformule
et enfin nous demande le consentement à
la personne pour lui donner un conseil
vous n'êtes pas kiné et du coup j'ai
imaginé d'autres situations vous allez
pouvoir utiliser ces conseils là ça
marche dans votre vie de couple ça
marche très bien avec les enfants ça
marche dans n'importe quelle situation
conflictuelle tout ça ce que je vous
explique je n'ai pas inventé un ça vient
des différentes techniques de
communication surmonte vous connaissez
mieux que moi vous avez appris à l'école
imaginez cet ami qui se remet sans cesse
avec son ex vous l'avez cet ami en tête
et elle vous dit je réponds quoi at home
et vous n'avez qu'une envie c'est lui
dire tu devrais arrêter lui parle et
hommes te fais du mal à chaque fois
c'est un c'est un looser j'avais dit
autre chose c'est un looser on va être
saft pour tom
vous avez envie de l'aider mais en fait
si vous dites ça ça va pas marcher avec
tom c'est chiant donc elle vous dit je
réponds quoi at home ou l'écouté et vous
reformuler qu'attends tu de cette
relation avec ton ex
vous dire bah franchement je ne sais pas
ok on lui demande son consentement pour
pouvoir lui proposer des conseils ça te
dirait qu'on essaie de comprendre avant
de lire un conte
est là au lieu lui donner directement un
conseil vous avez juste lui donner des
outils pour qu'elle se remette en
question pour savoir quel est son besoin
réel
de revoir comme ça marche aussi notre
situation où vous l'avez sûrement ce
copain la doucette à millas
qui se plaint tout le temps parce qu'il
est célibataire et qui trouve pas la
bonne personne j'ai pris des exemples
adapté à l'audience
surmonter quinze ans en arrière ce que
nous nos problématiques c'est plutôt
quel crédit on va réussir à négocier est
ce que le jardin est assez grand pour la
maison et vraie problématique quel film
on regarde ce soir sur netflix bref
votre collègue et là il vous dit je suis
fatigué je ne sais plus quoi faire
aucune femme de venoix
votre première répond ce serait lui dire
brestois les dents et fred
ça marche pas vous allez lui briser le
coeur 10 ans a
écouté reformuler demander le
consentement
je suis fatigué je sais plus quoi faire
machin tout ok est-ce que tu serai ok
pour que je te dise qu'on pourrait
améliorer chez toi
bonsoir les dents et fred
quels amis formidables
donc de toute façon dans les deux cas il
se serait brosser les dents mais il y en
a une il va la terre à contrecoeur
l'autre qui va se dire je vais optimiser
mes chances de réussite
parce que je veux vous expliquer c'est
que ce concept de marshall rosenberg
connect before correct qui vient de la
communication non violente c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut expliquer et appliquée
a beaucoup beaucoup de choses commencer
par écouter
reformuler
demander le consentement avant
d'expliquer
et si possible dans les explications
soyez fun soyez clairs et soyez concis
merci beaucoup pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]